so you've heard of Generation X and
Generation Y you've heard of Millennials
and baby boomers now let me introduce
you to Generation porn as the name
suggests we have a generation who are
now growing up with often unrestricted
access to adult porn material for free
pioneering new rules were due to come
into play this month to make sure porn
sites check their users are aged over 18
but there is a flaw in the plan this age
verification doesn't extend to Google or
social media sites and given that over
half of primary school children and now
accessing social media sites and
children as young as 11 a regular
viewing porn on these sites it's clear
we've got a problem
parents are gone are the days of a
couple of dogged porn magazines doing
the rounds your children now have free
and regular access to intense porn
scenes at the click of a button they act
they are exposed to what the porn world
views as normal when it comes to sex
consent and relationship and the damage
that that can do to young minds should
not be underestimated
we need to make sure that Generation
porn becomes Generation monitored
generation educated and generation
protected
[Music]
miss Michelle absolutely spot-on and I
can't disagree with anything you just
said there I think this is really
serious and and if you look at it I
don't think that our government is
looking at this as seriously as they
should do in the sense that we know that
we would not in any way want children of
this age group participating in any of
the sorts of events that happen on those
videos so therefore why don't we see as
equally as dangerous for them to be
watching that in terms of how it over
sexualizes children and we won't really
know what the ramifications of this
stuff is until Generation porn become
adults I have a friend called Cindy
Gallup that does a lot of work in this
space could make love not poor and then
this is something that she flagged up
about five five years ago so as
something that we will should be
worrying about and that's what you were
saying about porn becoming the sort of
the normal idea for sex the stats
suggests that 53% of 11 to 16 year old
boys see porn as a realistic depiction
of sex again what that means for girls
in itself is frightening what survey
this and this is this is this when I
read this quit at frightens the tripod
me this is a woman called shine Louise
Houston she's an avid filmmaker she says
I wish that people would just consider
porn just another film genre because
that's what it is
but there's this weird thing that
happens with porn that somehow people
can't totally switch off their
suspension of disbelief and I think
that's partly marketing and that's all
that's what it's not it's it's film it's
an illusion when you have that kind of
attitude it's no wonder that the
relevant steps are being taken out to
stop it but you know I think you talked
we're talking about Paul but it's it's a
much wider argument with smartphone
addiction AB you know that kids now are
becoming addicted to their devices and
in a way you know it was supposed to
make communication easier paradoxically
it's made it worse in that no one talks
to each other anymore you know kid you
know kid this this the social what do
you my works been exaggerated
nobody talks to in video well the young
people communicate less yes marching on
they communicate but in a different way
no human development in terms of social
intelligence the interaction we might be
running away the generalizations what is
what is clear is social media has has
been largely unregulated in a year since
it came and smog was and it cannot
continue and therefore the next 20 years
is all about regulation and how do you
do it I think are in all sorts of areas
of social media social media but
particularly in in terms of was porn
block do you know about this I read it
deserts how does it how does it work so
the way is and by the way its worst
thing it's supposed to be coming out on
the 15th of July and delayed again for
the song I'm due to what they're calling
administrative problems so what they do
is if you're a commercial or a
generalized porn site before you get so
when someone comes to your website
you've now got to have a landing page
that has static content so you're not
immediately landing on yeah that's the
first thing the second thing is then
you've got to verify that your user is
aged over the age of 18 and there's a
few different ways of doing that so you
can do a check based on credit cards
passports or things IMS onto your phone
you can go down to the high street and
buy like your age verified voucher that
you can then apply and once you've
verified your age one but then go anyone
could get a voucher then it just makes
it harder the key point here is that a
lot of parents don't understand that's a
view poor and you don't have to go to a
pawn site anymore
most children a watching porn on things
like Twitter and when you actually look
at and the history the browsing history
you look on Twitter it's very hard to
see it you what videos your children are
watching and all you've got to do is
take one thing and this is why I want to
make parents aware cuz I'm astonished by
how many parents don't even check their
kids smartphone in their history that
blows my mind
but you've got to be mother I know
safeguards on Twitter
yeah no idea at all of what your
children are doing online because for
research purposes only obviously of
course last night I
when on the sweet side what a night you
had it was yeah it was a great evening
involve came from Germany still talking
but I sat down and all I did is said
that I was 30 and I own 60 and I own
ticked the thing to say I can see
sensitive stuff and the stuff that I saw
I got hairs on my chest and I'm a woman
of the world I just go through your last
24 hours you said last time watching
german porn and this morning reading the
dictionary on deployments I live in the
drain Michelle
living the dream there was an image I
knew your son bill is 75% of parents say
they are concerned about this really
well you wondered what is the 25 I mean
oh I mean I'm just forever grateful that
my kids suing 30 different generation I
think bringing up kids today is much
much tougher I know if the whole thing
is that it will push kids towards
streaming sites and the dog-whip which
which no one is confirming that's it's
easier for them to get onto and that's
the big criticism of this pool block as
well as the thing with that though is if
you're a parent once you go onto the
dark web it does all sorts of things to
your computer not that I would know I've
been told and so if you're a parent and
your kid is on the dark web you will
know that if they're using the family
laptop for sure
I would never let I mean I don't have
children so it's easy to sit here and
pontificate what you wouldn't do
wouldn't do as a parent but I can't
imagine a scenario where I'd allow my
child to be upset only smartphone doing
god only knows to do things their
parents don't you did it I did their
browsing you're gonna where baby grows
until they're 16 they're not gonna leave
the house they're not going to talk to
people the opposite sex but they're not
gonna bro this is what Twitter say we
recognize that some people may not want
to be exposed to sensitive content which
is why we'd balance allowing people to
share this type of media with helping
people who want to avoid it to do so for
this reason you can't include violent
hateful or adult content within areas
that are highly visible on Twitter if
you share this content within tweet
you need to mark your account as
sensitive under this policy there are
also some types of sensitive media
content that we don't allow at all
because they have the potential to
normalize violence and cause distress to
those who view them I tell you one thing
Michele reading again these background
notes you quite rightly highlights and
teenagers benardos are talking about
children they're not in this area being
so at the age of five getting hooked
yeah and my primary concern and I or I
sound like a stuck record but I really
worry about what porn is doing to
particularly boys particularly they get
in their sex education comments and
their expert what is the real goes I
would really suggest is probably worse
for the girls also I do think the other
thing that we should worry about as well
is the fact that most of the politicians
are not tech savvy so they don't
understand how this stuff works we
actually need more unlesss unless it
Boris's understand it really so it's
never gonna work you think the point the
reason why it's all is being postponed
is actually it's very difficult to do
I've been son yeah